so me out so now you gonna end up with a
bullet and you're here for it you can't
play me mother I'm the
that plays mother
mother cat Nigel that's great
oh it's smashing thank you so much yeah
well it's been an absolute honor and
what a great opportunity to be here and
be able to play an American tough well
I'm just so glad that we got you out of
that BBC commitment so you can play with
us
Antoine listen I'm just not buying that
you're someone that was born raised in
the streets of Brooklyn that's weird
cuz I actually was born and raised on
the streets of Brooklyn I wasn't a gang
and everything most of this stuff
actually happened to me
Wow okay well that's that's that's great
for us cuz I want you to use it okay
it's good first tank let's just uh let's
get going it let's go let's get going
thank you - scene five take two and
action
you sold me out son now you gonna end up
with a bullet in your head for me you
can't play me mother I'm the
that plays mother
mobile
cut cut
okay Nigel that was great Oh brilliant
just really the way you move especially
when you talk I just really see this
character coming to life before my eyes
kiss is just this fabulous and when your
performance um it's just not quite there
yet okay I really need to see you make
more of a transformation okay like like
Nigel here that dude's British and if I
might jump in with a bit of advice I
don't think I need caramel maybe you
might want to try thinking of something
in the material that's similar to
something that's happened to no real
life but for me for instance I like to
think of when me mum wanted me to attend
prep school in Leeds to become a
barrister but I wanted to study the
theater at Oxford thank God and so that
was a conundrum really for me more
staffy right right there
cuz it's just confusing me right like I
don't need that cuz I am from the
streets I was in a gang they told me to
kill my cousin a bitch Sports Hall you
know yeah it's a bit spot-on do you have
any stories that involve your mum what's
the mum yeah
scene five take three okay antwuan
remember you're a gangster okay betrayal
the streets
okay Nigel you're perfect and one
transform and action you sold me out son
now you're gonna get a bit up in your
hair for it you can't play me mother
that plays
he's boring to watch cut does not sound
good and I do not feel like you have
found the emotional core of this
character man this nobody is more
real than me okay I come from the
streets and nobody's going to tell me
what the streets is like nobody you
understand that's a great speech I just
wish that I believed it you want to give
it a shot I'll have a go man this
I'm as will yes yes this is freezes
for real I'ma be in there man you are
from the from the from
the are from the streets from the start
something today
no but I'm so with you I'm with you when
you say that even when you're saying the
wrong words I just wish you could do
that okay that hurts but I don't feel
that it comes from the right emotional
place for the character all right here
give it a shot give me what watch watch
that's great I feel that you're here and
in here